screen junkies show with how Rudnick hey
everybody welcome to a really special
edition of screen junkies so why cuz I'm
wearing a tie oh yeah and we're playing
Twilight trivia we have gathered the
most die-hard Twihards to compete for
two tickets to the red-carpet premiere
of Twilight Breaking Dawn Part two but
here's a little secret there dads are
actually going to be answering the
questions so let's bring out our
Twilight fans come on in let's meet our
contestants Taylor how old are you 11
years old Twilight is my hands-down my
favorite movie ever follow up question
do you like any good movies just kidding
we love Twilight Sarah how old are you
I'm 15 years old
would you rather hang out with Edward
from Twilight or Justin Bieber Oh Edward
Edward Allie how old are you I'm 13
13 if you met Taylor Lautner Jacob in
real life what would you say to him he's
one of my favorite actors and I love him
in the movie he's just amazing we have a
very special treat for you guys
Robert Pattinson let's ring out Robert
Pattinson I am kidding okay Robert
Pattinson is not here but your dads are
here right dads please wave to the
camera say hi to us we have dads
watching their daughters proud excellent
are you guys ready to play the game yes
you're not playing the game your dads
are gonna be playing the game oh that's
right the fate of you going to the
Twilight premiere rests in the hands of
your father yes you're not going to the
premieres but are you excited about that
no no
all right let's make the awkward
transition to bring their dads in here
you gotta be kidding me
and we're back we made the switch the
dads are here the girls are upstairs
girls wave to your dad's dad's wave to
your girls Donnie I know your daughter
Taylor is upstairs feeling very nervous
about your chances yes I am
what do you want to say right into that
camera to reassure her right now don't
plan on going to this premiere coz we're
not waiting I'm gonna cry yeah Trevor
what do you want to say to Ally
I'm so sorry so here's how the game
works each of you is going to get an
individual question you answer correct
that's one point you answer incorrect
that's a negative point remember your
daughter's love hangs in the balance it
is first question which character has
his shirt off more often at work this is
Corey tango
Edward incorrect it's Jacob Wow
Kirk sure false Edward breaks up with
Bella in Twilight New Moon true you go
dad
forget it Trevor in what year was the
original Twilight released
Oh Leeds in 2000 she doesn't I'm going
to have to say 2008 correct I'd like to
direct you to the monitor where we have
some very special guests Donny
your next question comes from the
character who plays Carlisle Peter
Facinelli hello fellow dads my character
is the adopted father of which you
name one he's so hot I know right
name one of his children
Edward that is correct I'm so proud of
you Kirk
we have a question for you this is
coming from the character who played
Jasper Jackson Rathbone is the first
movie Bella and Jacob see together face
punch or kick face face punch Trevor
this next question for you comes from
the character who plays Esme Elizabeth
Reiser true or false
my character gives birth to a werewolf
I'll say false
that's right back around to Donnie who
wrote the Twilight books um no idea what
are you kidding me
Stephenie Meyer
yes you are in the first Twilight movie
do the Cullens play a game of football
baseball or Ultimate Frisbee baseball
yeah that's good you know what's true or
false the Twilight books are based off
the hit movie series Twilight balls
yeah correct which guy is the vampire
that Bela falls in love with the guy
with the shirt off is Jacob so that will
make Edward yes what did Bella and
Edward name their child no way
Renesmee I have known you Sara ah mr.
really hurting me I like yeah it's
really pretty or name my kid that name
my character is a vegetarian what do I
eat specifically vegetables my blood I
told him that am i vampire or a werewolf
good looks like a vampire go vampire
correct
hubby did which Twilight Breaking Dawn
actor one favorite Buttkicker what's
that guy's name you're not gonna move
Robert Pattinson or whatever his name is
how many times has Jacob kissed Bella oh
how many times he kissed her twice in
the moon and once it eclipsed what we
are currently believe it or not in a
three-way tie what gentlemen we have a
tiebreaker
we have the original Twilight book I am
going to read you a quote oh my god and
it is up to you to tell me what page
number it's from the page number the
person that comes closest to guessing
what page this quote is on is our Victor
oh no oh no
I'm going to read this quote once and
only once
Edwards seem to take a deep breath and
then he stepped out into the bright glow
of the middle days beginnings in the
beginning between like 100 maybe write
down your answers gentlemen whoever
comes closest to guessing the actual
page number is going to the red carpet
premiere and after-party of the final
Twilight movie thank God ah the suspense
is killing me
yes Sarah are you confident you can do
it dad or any of you close to crying I
am yes two of these men are gonna be
dealing with very pissed-off teenage
daughters Trevor I guessed 200 Kirk my
guess was 222 thank you sir and Donnie
for 47 for 47 in my hand I have several
cards on one of these cards are our
final results do you feel confident no
no sure girls how do you feel more
scared than I've ever felt in my entire
life a for effort
I'm afraid dad's the results are
Donnie you were 188 pages away Kirk
you were 37 pages away
Trevor you were 59 pages away our winner
going to the Twilight Breaking Dawn to
premier is Kirk and his daughter Sarah
girls I know one of you is happy and two
of you are very pissed off
come on down girls join your dad's I'm
sorry Sarah
how do you feel about your dad how do
you feel about the two losers really bad
they have a long drive home Taylor how
do you what do you have to say to your
dad oh I'm really proud of you still
thanks Ali
what do you have to say to your dad
Trevor well he tried and I think it did
pretty well well we brought you here not
only our Kirk and Sarah going to see the
Twilight Breaking Dawn to premiere all
three pairs Fargo
here on our tickets look at that look
how happy they are this is true joy what
more could you ask for feel like I've
done a service to humanity today folks
that's what we do here on screen junkies
we make dreams come true tune in next
week where we're doing another trivia
game based on the movie Lincoln thanks
for watching I'm how run dick by bike
yes we did it
the